la Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos concluyó su visita a Perú tras
reunirse con víctimas congresistas y la
presidenta constataron un clima de
extrema polarización y una fuerte
estigmatización étnica y regional
pidieron a la policía de atenerse a los
estándares e interamericanos e hicieron
un llamado lo que estamos instando es a
un diálogo amplio ese diálogo amplio
puede contener acuerdos Y esos acuerdos
tienen que originarse de esa amplia
representatividad y tienen que ser en el
marco del Estado de derecho sin acuerdo
político Así se ve la frontera entre
Perú y Bolivia los manifestantes
mantienen los bloqueos y decenas de
camiones llevan 10 días varados vamos a
permanecer Sí o sí acá hasta que se vaya
a la presidenta
Mientras tanto la presidenta Dina
boluarte trata de ganar aire ante la
comunidad internacional en la Cumbre
virtual de la voz del sur global dijo
que su gobierno promueve el diálogo por
la paz y la reconciliación esto en plena
crisis diplomática con México Colombia y
Bolivia y tras recibir un llamado de
atención de chile y Estados Unidos Mira
yo estoy bien preocupado porque
estamos corriendo el riesgo de aislar y
como El Ejecutivo no tiene bancada
parlamentaria no
como no tiene fuerza política ni aparato
político está asumiendo la agenda de
política exterior del Congreso es más de
los sectores más duros del Congreso de
la derecha temporal las protestas
estallaron el 8 de diciembre con el
intento de Pedro castillo de disolver El
Congreso esto derivó en su posterior
encarcelación acusado de darse un
autogolpe de estado los manifestantes se
rebelaron y ahora exigen la renuncia de
la presidenta el cierre del Congreso el
adelanto de elecciones a 2023 y la
convocatoria de una asamblea
Constituyente